deux séries de chiffres pour comprendre
pourquoi des infirmières et des
infirmiers français très tentés de venir
pratiquer au québec
d'abord le revenu les infirmières en
france sont parmi les moins bien payés
de tous les pays industrialisés
l'ebit statisticiens de l'oscd qui ont
calculé le salaire de base les primes et
les heures supplémentaires
résultat une infirmière en france gagne
en moyenne 55 mille dollars canadiens
par année au canada pour le même travail
elles touchent en moyenne 71 1000
dollars canadiens toujours selon l'étude
de l'oscd bref en traversant
l'atlantique
l'infirmière françaises vont voir son
salaire augmenter d'environ 23% après le
salaire mais ya le coût de la vie à
montréal avec 1200 dollars par mois
vous pouvez trouver facilement un
appartement bien situé et qui compte au
moins deux chambres à coucher à paris
avec le même 1200 dollars canadiens par
mois vous devez vous contenter d'un
minuscule studio d'à peine 20 mètres
carrés ou si vous préférez 226 cas
[Musique]